hello everyone this is Samir from audio
review back with another product review
in this case is the shit's uh new Bal
headphone amplifier and preamp called
the
midgard um you can see a picture of it
there and uh sort of looks just like the
picture um it's the back of it uh
typical of shed products that put the
power switch in the back I like to turn
off my headphone amp when I'm not using
it so not a big fan of that but you get
used to feeling in the back and turning
it off um the front controls have nice
feel to them these there's a gain switch
and an input switch between RCA and XLR
um they use these symbols International
symbols I think everybody understands
English so I encourage them to put the
word gain on them so you don't have to
go read the manual to figure out what
they do it has uh both a balanced uh X
balanced uh it has an
XLR um connection four pin XLR for
balance headphones and a quarter inch um
in many products the balanced XLR output
actually has four times the power uh of
the uh quarter inch um but not in this
case actually the same power uh but the
company claims there's a little bit of
magic in here where if you use the XLR
uh output it's able to sense its
feedback uh through this connection and
and uh theoretically compensate for uh
uh um issues related to the loading that
the headphone provides we'll uh test for
that uh at least in a direct way um
other than that not much else to talk
about I like the look of uh the product
it's very sturdy uh it's only
$219 which is uh quite low cost for a
metal case and uh you know this level of
uh configuration but let's see how it
performs um for all the testing I use
the XLR input over here here uh I didn't
bother testing the preamp outputs
because they're usually the same as the
headphone output with just a resistor in
series I think the company says there 75
ohm output so you could imagine
everything I'm showing you would be
representative of the uh preamp output
as well so starting with quarter inch
output and feeding the amp um 4 volts it
has a nice uh Unity gain mode which
means that doesn't amplify anything then
you can use the volume control to lower
the output so I give it four volts and I
set the volume to max and I get four
volts out which is nice and this is the
performance that we get Distortion
products are below minus 120 DBS which
means you're guaranteed to not hear them
and but there's a bit of noise that
degrades that down to
118 um switching to uh XLR output uh
performance doesn't change it's exactly
the same company says that you have to
have a real headphone load so maybe with
that would make a difference I don't
know I don't think they have
measurements to show either a difference
so at least in this on a bench test
there's no difference between the two
but to be on the safe side all the rest
of the measurements that you see are
with the XLR output tab um plotting were
this combination of noise and Distortion
as expressed in sinad lands uh it goes
in here best case uh devices are at 121
DB we're at minus we're at 118 so about
3 DB short of state-ofthe-art so not not
bad at all and as I mentioned you B
basically have transparency on this
thing
anyway um just measuring Noise by itself
rather than combination of noise and
Distortion we see that we get 123 DB
which is better than 20 bits uh so
guaranteed transparency as far as noise
level if you're listening with a
insensitive headphone um but if you have
an ultra sensitive imem I also measure
with just 50 MTS out instead of 4 volts
so much lower output level there it
really stresses the uh the amplifier and
we get a number about 88 89 DB um you
can't read this graph on the video but
best case is about 94 DB we're at
8889 so again near the top of the class
but not quite to get to the top of the
class you need to have a headphone amp
with negative gain so actually de
amplifies even at max volume and that'll
get you 3db or so so the company wants
they compete in this game they should
have uh include a third gain setting
that's that's even lower amplification
when with lower amplification noise
level goes
down um back to Distortion instead of
just one Kilz that we measured so far we
can measure with 32 tones that go from
20 HZ to 20 khz and we see that
Distortion the inter modulation products
are way down here below -20 DP so again
full transparency across the full
spectrum
we can also measure one frequency at a
time and we get essentially the same
thing the numbers are a little bit lower
because we're measuring across 90 K
bandwidth so way past audible band and
still extremely good and basically
doesn't care what frequency you
heated same with frequency response you
know as I measure from 10 Herz to 100
khz and it's basically ruler flood
across that full spectrum so you know
you could uh use this to magnify to
amplify AM radio if you want it it's a
quite wide band and good
state-of-the-art preamps and headphone
amps tend to be this good but just know
that there is no tonality to this app it
say transparent as far as tonality is
concerned as as you can possibly get a
way past audible
band um this amplifier like many of it
like it has an analog volume control and
analog volume controls start to lose
accuracy have the lowest settings
company uses a nice uh Po from Alps and
I don't know if they're doing their own
pre-screening to find the good ones but
the sample that I have has extremely
good Channel B balance this Dash blue
line is a difference between the two
channels as I literally grab the tone
the volume control for Max and I man
manually turn it to zero and as I'm
turning it the analyzers determining how
much uh uh attenuation I'm getting with
this red line and also what the channel
difference is
and I measure 05 DB as when it uh is
unacceptable and you can see until you
get to this point uh here uh Channel
matching is well below half a DB and as
soon as you go there it jumps to One DB
error but at this point if we go over
here we see that it's 60 DB or 65 DB of
attenuation which is plenty so I don't
think you're going to hear a channel IM
balance issue uh with sensitive IMS and
sensitive headphones uh or if if you
have sensitive ears and listen very low
volumes but uh there's a bit of a luck
of a draw in here and that uh you know
they reaching a bin aparts and put them
in there and some may be worse than this
product I don't know without testing
like 50 of them you'll never know but
it's a good indicator that uh Channel
balance is very good perhaps the most
important thing in a headphone amplifier
for measurement is how much power it has
because once you run out of power like
here and you start clipping Distortion
gets so bad that uh the amp becomes
unusable I don't care if you're
subjectivist or objectivist once the
thing gets so distorted everybody can
hear it so you want as much power as you
can get and it's very difficult to get
power with high impedance so this first
test is with a 300 oh load uh that means
you need to have a lot of voltage to get
power and this have gets nearly 3/4 of a
little bit more than 34s of wat in my
measurements and uh its own spec is only
750 so we actually beating its spe and
my threshold is about 100 milliamps so
as soon as you have 100 milliamps you
have a capable uh I mean sorry mwatts
you have a capable headphone amp uh and
here we have 7 or eight times that so
that means that even if you have a high
impedance headphone let's say it's a 600
ohm headphone where you get less power
you should still have ample amount of
Drive capability drive basically any
High impedance headphone uh just about
there's some crazy headphones out that
require speaker amps to drive them but
putting that aside you're basically
future proof in high impedance at low
impedance it uh um still has excellent
amount of power 4 and a half Watts or so
and it gets a little bit more distorted
and one channel gets more distorted than
the other uh but still this is extremely
good uh to have more than one or two
watts is what I like to see and we're
we're into four to five
Watts um but those are two uh loads um
what happens with other loads well if
you have a headphone that has a 50 ohm
uh um impedance what do you get so I run
this test where I start at 600 ohm and
step all the way down to just 12 ohm uh
there are iems that actually go as low
as 8 oh so and depending on what
headphone you have you can look at it
and find the nearest Value and look at
the graphs in here uh basically at um
600 and 300 oh performance is the same
it uh doesn't really care but once you
go below that it starts to lose uh
voltage and progressively loses a little
bit more a little bit more so when it
lose voltage um you know you have less
capable uh headphone app and then below
that some interesting happen which I
haven't seen is that it actually shuts
down the protection circuit and it
doesn't let it uh uh produce more power
at the 20 ohm and Below uh it actually
limits you to this but since the
impedance is very low you actually get
quite a bit of power but just know that
this is an amp that much happier driving
uh extremely high impedance lows a
little bit less happy driving low
impedance but even in that we see the
distortions are all at minus 95us 100 DB
so quite capable in here again just a
hair away from
Perfection so how does it sound I
actually test every headphone am do a
listening test why do I do a listening
test
because this with special test clips
that I have is actually easy to
determine when an app is getting
distorted basically sound gets very
distorted crackling some apps mute so I
want to listen to that and and get a you
know firstand experience dve than doing
psycho Acoustics analysis at all power
levels so for testing I start usually
with these uh Dan Clark Dan Clark
stealth headphones it's a quite
expensive $4,000 headphones um beside
their power their cost they also
extremely power hungry and one of the
least sensitive headphones that I've
tested they also very low impedance I
think down 32 ohm so for this amplifier
this is very very stressful kind of
headphone but uh the uh midgard had no
trouble driving it I had to crank it all
the way to 300 p.m. so maybe just you
know quarter of a turn left as far as
headr and beyond that it got distorted
but at that level it was incredibly loud
and I could hear my ear loopes resonate
with Bas frequencies no I don't do that
for more than one or two seconds so
don't worry about my hearing um but I do
grank it up just to see where that limit
beyond that got really really distorted
but you wouldn't continuously listen
even at that 300 p.m. you know so I did
bulk of my listening after that around I
don't know 1 or 2:00 in High Gain and it
was just incredibly powerful and and
very good sound just not infinite amount
of power but if you switch the the
Sennheiser um hd6 50s or all these
clones and variations this is a 300 ohm
impedance uh headphon so opposite of the
Dan Clark and an order magnitude more
sensitive than than Clark with these at
12:00 there was just base that you would
not believe the detail was superb
Fidelity was just fantastic uh was it
more fantastic than many of the other
AMS up there something now but it's just
you know with the right content that's
slow Distortion and clean recording it's
just amazingly good sound I just wanted
to sit there and keep listening um I did
test with both of them the XLR versus
the quarter inch with the Dan Clark I
thought that essentially the same but
maybe the XLR was just a hair less good
with the uh HT 650 I thought the XLR
sounded a little bit better but those
kinds of differences are so fleeting and
so small that it could just be a
function of my site of testing and it
takes about you know a few seconds to
switch from one to the other by the time
you do that your memory is long gone you
need to be able to do instantaneous AB
to be able to find small differences so
really there's just nothing there to
worry about you know just use whatever
connection is convenient uh for you so
what's the bottom line is that is a
superbly powerful and transparent uh
headphone amp the midgard is um and is
priced to compete at the same level that
you get from uh products from far East
as the one of few companies that's able
to keep up with with those manufacturers
and produce now extremely well measuring
well performing objectively and
subjectively products with good
construction yet bargain prices $219
especially in this day and age with
inflation and everything it's not much
money so uh it's just amazing that they
can keep up and and make a living uh uh
selling product um as usual I always
recommend getting balanced products and
this one has balanced XLR inputs which
is what's important you don't really
need balanc XLR output if you have
enough power which this one has and what
that gives you is incredible amount of
noise immunity with respect to ground
loops and once you've had a ground Loop
you'll you'll hate that forever uh use
balance stck with this they're very lowc
cost balance Stacks from shet that
matches that or some other one up to you
but if you're really into computer audio
it's just you're asking for for trouble
using unbalanced Stu spend an extra $50
$100 for the amp versus the and the deac
and get yourself balanced iio and and
you're in business okay so great
products uh definitely recommend it and
uh if you're in US you enjoy buying
locally uh distribution overseas is not
as good so I don't know how good of fit
it is if you're outside us but in us
it's it's a it's a great choice okay see
you in a future video bye-bye